bonsoir bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors moment new order est un groupe qui
a été fondée
par ian curtis voilà parler d'abord new
order a été fondée par les trois
survivants du groupe joy division après
le suicide du chanteur ian curtis
effectivement en 1981 et effectivement
le tube de joy division c'était ça
love will tear us apart qui a été classé
6ème meilleures chansons de tous les
temps par les anglais dernièrement vous
fait plaisir
c'est d'être dans les cinq autres
chansons ça a été entamée dès le premier
enfant de construire aussi ce bon c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal pris en fait cette
chanson là où il tient à sparte raconte
la rupture de ian curtis avec sa femme
deborah curtis quelques mois avant de se
pendre dans sa cuisine et cette chanson
est sortie sur l'album posthume de joy
division qui s'appelle closer voilà
alors love will tear us apart et
d'ailleurs l'épitaphe qui est sur la
tombe de ian curtis
épitaphe demandez pas par sa femme
deborah curtis qui a écrit une
biographie de son mari une biographie
très controversé qui servira de trame à
un film consacré à ian curtis tu alors
jen division' c'était les femmes
déportées
forcées de se prostituer avec les
dignitaires nazis ça fait un scandale
quand le groupe est apparu sur la scène
britannique non
oui en effet scandale c'est un grand mot
disons que on a peut-être mal
interprétés le nom du groupe et quand
vous êtes appelés new order ça a été
encore un scandale parce que new order
ça veut dire ordre nouveau quand même
je sais pas il ya toujours ce petit
billet de ce mandat peut être aussi la
donne non ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
a pu démontrer au fil des années et que
en fait ces pensées n'avait aucun sens
et que quel que soit le nom du groupe
havas est simplement l'étiquette qu'on
donne à la musique ce que nous a tous
convaincus d'autres et avec les années
c'est que c'est une autre musique qui
compte pas loin du groupe il ya pas de
10 des politiques par exemple alors vous
avez changé de nom et s'appeler jay-z
les jeunes et après new order parce que
vous aviez décidé que s'il y en a un qui
quittait le groupe quelle que soit la
raison pour laquelle il quitte le groupe
le groupe devait changer de nom c'est un
accord entre vous c'est un deal entre
vous
oui c'était un deal entre nous pourquoi
parce qu'elle estimait que si
il manquait quelqu'un à ce statut elle
même chose effectivement c'est ce qui
s'est passé et puis d'ailleurs
production d'agneaux frappe de diego
après la mort de yann quartier c'était
quand même quelque chose c'était un choc
et nous tout ça c'est important du real
et de redémarrer sur une nouvelle passe
c'est ce qu'on a fait de très bien
puisque ensuite la fête plus demandés et
puis c'est vrai mais pratiquement le
meilleur groupe du coin bien sûr alors
ensuite effectivement le groupe s'éteint
progressivement à l'aube des années 90
comme orlando silence silence les
braults que c'est un la page excuse moi
ok ok ok autant pour moi alors mon fou
changeant notre boulot
le groupe s'est apprécié notamment l'ong
au
silence et alors le groupe n'a pas
vraiment splitté mais vous n'êtes pas
adressé la parole pendant cinq ans
pourquoi
pas mal de problèmes à l'époque et puis
des problèmes quand y ait des problèmes
c'est que on se défoule un petit peu sur
ses proches sur ce problème
bon je crois que c'est quelque chose du
manager faiblesse de l'homme et pisé ce
qui s'est passé on s'est tapé dessus
alors que la chaîne ait beaucoup et il
n'a pas pu sortir de des problèmes
financiers d'ailleurs que de
reconstruire on avait une boîte chapelle
à l'hacienda j'espère que c'est plein de
drogue et d'armes à feu ce n'était
peut-être pas le meilleur endroit de
fête ont pas cessé samedi soir enfin la
finance et aux jeunes gens nés des bons
souvenirs aux autres oui glisse à part
cette histoire disons que il nous
fallait faire un break les uns par
rapport aux autres il n'y a pas beaucoup
qui attendent d'intenses d'arriver au
sommet de leur carrière pour ensuite
faire un break de six ans et on
recommence et après on observa c'est
important mais soit on est très
courageuse wall est complètement stupide
non en fait ce qui s'est passé si vous
étiez complètement carbonisé par vos
tournées à l'époque c'est à dire que
faisait des des concerts l'an le matin
vous prenez l'avion ou des fonciers à
mort vous arrivez à un moment où vous
étiez complètement cuit non c'est ça oui
ben vous étiez là que vous savez tout ça
une des scènes très pénibles
en 2001 vous avez sorti goût tall qui
était la bande originale du film the
beach la plage ensuite un album qui
s'est appelée get ready et aujourd'hui
donc vous sortez votre huitième album
qui s'appelle waiting for de sierentz to
call en attendant l'appel des sirènes
voilà très bien accueilli par la
critique
publique en france je sais pas en
angleterre mais en france la critique
est dithyrambique
le
disque arrive jamais au bon moment parce
que on est tellement pris par tout ce
qu'on a fait il est en plein dans le
projet de sortie donc on n'arrive pas à
savoir si la musique est pas du lot
parce qu'on est pris de temps donc il
faut prendre un peu de recul je te
mangerais disions en quelque sorte la
merci des films voir ce que ça donne et
puis si nous et qui écrivent des
des salons et on revient avec un nouveau
disque on se défend bien si on continue
et on aime ça ben c'est ça qui est sympa
je dois dire que moi j'ai toujours aimé
ça et il faut alors l'atmosphère est
plus joyeuse sur cet album là que sur le
précédent gap crédit et pourtant vous
l'avez enregistré dans un château
médiéval celui de l'actrice jane seymour
à baffes dans la chambre de dracula à la
lueur des bougies et c c'est étonnant
que finalement l'atmosphère de l'album
soit aussi joyeuse
de tirer le meilleur parti des
circonstances un peu noir quand il fait
froid dehors lorsqu'il ya les fantômes
qui commencent à apparaître bon c'est
une blague c'est vrai qu'on a trouvé un
squelette de bébés dans ce dans ce
château
nous a dit c'est en rapport avec henri 8
est l'une de ses maîtresses
c'était un match en double c'est une
chambre dernière arrivée parce que sa
voiture la plus notre arrivée le dernier
il a eu de mauvaises choses
jusque là du bébé était dans la
cheminées le lit était envahie aussi
fallu faire le lycée
louis tremblay c'est vraiment incroyable
et surtout trop petit parce qu'à
l'époque il était plus petit maintenant
non
oui c'était l'époque les gens étaient
vraiment petit au xviie siècle donc il
faut dormir comme c'est mon ressenti à
petit je crois à bon je n'avais pas à
peu près comme ça vous êtes et personnel
non mais or depuis
ça sonne vraiment un très bon cru des
années 80 quoi c'est la jeune shoshanna
on préfère des progrès mais 80 mais
disons que
rapport à mesure qu'on vieillit on se
rend compte que le monde est plein de
busan et il n'est pas divisée entre les
it is the night is toi je fais de la
musique depuis l'âge de 21 ans je
continuerai jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
ouais alors évidemment quand on pense à
vous on pense au film de michael
winterbottom
24 heures party people as tu l'as vu ce
film
groupe i am looking
g
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu